there are a lot of misconceptions out
there and this is a video about one of
the most common ones so I went around
asking people what makes the moon go
around the earth and they told me the
earth puts a gravitational force on the
moon but does the moon put a
gravitational pull on the earth pull on
the earth yes it does
hence we have tides etc the moon falls
on the earth too it affects like the
tides and women and yes it does very
powerful
ok does the moon pull on the earth
probably that as well yeah so what I
want to know is how does that force that
the moon exerts on the earth how does
that compare in terms of size to the
force the earth exerts on the moon Wow
no scientist but I think that one would
be more powerful than that one it's got
a greater force coming from the earth
because it's great a mass is the earth
has more mass cuz it's a bigger mess I
thought greater mass is more equals more
force guys the moon pull on the earth
yes but a lot less yeah not as much as
the earth pulls on the moon yeah yeah
but a little bit not very strongly yes
but much much much much smaller because
if it's mass less not size because it's
smaller it's much smaller than that than
the earth because it's smaller this is
small allow me to let you in on a little
secret everyone got it wrong the force
that attracts the moon to the earth is
exactly the same size as the force that
attracts the earth to the moon so what's
going on here why did everyone get it
wrong well I think it comes down to
cause and effect the effect of the force
on the moon is quite clear the moon goes
in circles around the earth but the
effect of that force on the earth is
basically negligible the earth barely
wobbles at all so people interpret this
negligible effect as indicating there's
very little force affecting the earth
but that is forgetting the third key
piece of the puzzle which is inertia
inertia is the tendency
of mass to maintain state of motion
since the earth has a greater mass it
has a greater inertia and so even with
the same amount of force on it it
doesn't accelerate that much now the
funny thing is many of the people I
interviewed could state Newton's third
law which is every force has not equal
and opposite reaction
something about Newton's law doesn't
seem to fit into that just yet you're
good at this
wait which Newton's law are we talking
about the whole equal and opposite force
thing yeah that one so tell me what
you're thinking man ah well did one
would think that if you're into putting
a force on me I would be putting an
equal force upon it so why didn't they
apply it to this problem well I think
they may have memorized the words but
not really believed Newton's third law
in their core did they really feel it in
their spleen I don't think they did so
allow me to try to convince you all of
you spleen included that Newton's third
law really is true let's consider two
objects initially they have the same
mass 1 kilogram each so obviously the
gravitational force of attraction must
be the same on both of the objects now
let's add a second kilogram to the first
object the force on the second object
will now be twice as great because that
1 kilogram is attracted equally to each
of the kilograms in the first object but
what is often forgotten is that Nooh
kilogram is also attracted to the second
object meaning that the total force on
each object is still the same they're
attracted to each other with an equal
and opposite force we could add a third
kilogram and we would find the same
thing the force on both objects is still
the same even though the object on the
left has 3 times the mass of the object
on the right so we can see that no
matter what the mass any two objects
will have the same gravitational force
towards each other
can you feel Newton's third law in your
lene now it should settle inside you and
become a part of you